[музика]
Росія відкрито завдає ударів по
українській енергетиці через це міста
занурюються в темряву тисячі людей
залишаються без світла води і тепла
на скільки постраждала інфраструктура з
10 по 21 жовтня російські ракети і дрони
нанесли близько 400 ударів по
українських об'єктах енергетики під час
останнього масованого обстрілу 31 жовтня
постраждали 18 об’єктів у 10 регіонах
Володимир Зеленський на зустрічі з
єврокомісаркою з питань енергетики кадрі
Сімсон заявив що пошкоджено 40% усієї
енергетичної інфраструктури України
здебільшого постраждали не генеруючи
потужності електростанції Це доволі
міцні і захищені споруди які не просто
зруйнувати обстрілами Тож вони
продовжують виробляти струм
за даними центру досліджень енергетики
загалом енергокомплекс України здатен
видавати 57 гігават електроенергії
близько 11 гігабат це потужності на
окупованих територіях тоді як пікова
потреба споживачів нині 13 Гб але
російські ракети б'ють переважно по
розподільчих підстанціях через це
вироблений струм стає неможливо
доставити до споживачів
атакується система транспортування
електрики це то якщо так провести якусь
аналогію то атакуються Highway по яких
передається електроенергія на думку
експертів мета російських обстрілів
розбити енергосистему України на окремі
сегменти фактично створити окремі
острівки українські енергосистемі де
один чи той інший район будуть мати
коефіцієнти електричної енергії а інший
регіон буде мати дефіцит електричної
енергії і саме ті злочинні цільові удари
унеможливлюють перетік електричної
енергії з регіону профіцитного за
наявності електричної енергії до регіону
з дефіцитом електричної енергії
Наскільки швидко можна відновити
інфраструктуру у міненерго зазначають Що
росіяни Б'ють по об'єктах які
відновлювати найважче деякі підстанції
руйнують заново вже після
найбільша проблема нині обладнання на
підстанціях воно дороге і виготовляється
під замовлення подекуди треба чекати до
9 місяців у групі ДТЕК заявили що запас
обладнання на їхніх складах уже
вичерпано Утім Олександр Харченко який
залучений до переговорів з ЄС про
енергетичну допомогу запевняє що Європа
попри низку труднощів готова допомагати
Україні з технікою і запчастинами
особливістю української енергосистеми
вони в тому числі полягають в
використанні нами лінії в 750 кіловольт
найпотужніших а Європа не використовує
лінії вище ніж 400 кВт тому певні класи
обладнання вони взагалі відсутні в
складському режимі навіть в аварійних
складах але сьогодні ми просто бачимо як
партнери дійсно Ну там часом навіть
ідуть напевне послаблення свого
резервування для того щоб нам швидше
допомогти за словами експертів оскільки
Європа останнім часом відмовлялася від
теплових електростанцій у ЄС можуть бути
запаси вживаного обладнання в
українському МЗС повідомили що
домовилися про поставки енергетичного
обладнання з 12 країн чи допоможе імпорт
струму з Європи Україна має технічну
можливість імпортувати струм з Європи
однак у цьому питанні є багато але
повторення українська енергосистема
синхронізувалася з європейською після
цього Україна почала експортувати
електроенергію в Європу адже виробляла
більше ніж споживала продавати
український струм у Європі можна було
дорожче тож це було вигідно для
трейдерів а от купувати європейську
електрику тепер доведеться завдвічі
вищими цінами можна також попросити у
Євросоюзу про аварійну допомогу струм
надаватиметься безкоштовно Але такий
самий обсяг електроенергії за певний час
треба буде повернути Європі крім того
пропускні спроможності України щодо
імпорту струму з Європи технічно
обмежені приблизно 500 МБ цього звісно
Недостатньо тому що Наприклад одне
промислове підприємство споживає або
потребує потужність для своєї
повноцінної роботи 40 МБ тому ми можемо
оцінити що аварійні можливості вони є
але вони доволі
Чи можливий повний блокаут
під тотальним блокаутом енергетики
розуміють повну некерованість
енергетичної системи нині до цього ще
далеко стверджують аналітики Разом з тим
коли саме українська енергетика перетне
межу стійкості невідомо адже удари по
енергосистемі такого масштабу
відбуваються в історії Вперше
це повний розпаду енергосистеми який за
собою веде до багаточисельних
технологічних катастроф і якщо
відбудеться реальний блокаут це буде
означати що просто що бере стратанути
наші генераційні потужності і
перезапустити мережу знадобиться два
тижні щонайменше опитані DW експерти не
вважають сценарії ймовірним але визнають
що перейти на газ там де це можливо не
буде зайвим
газ транспорт
на система Якщо є можливість
домогосподарств України Якщо є
можливість промислових підприємствах
комерційних установах
замістити хоча б частково використання
електричної енергії наприклад тим самим
природним газом Це потрібно зробити
водночас у міненерго наголошують що
запорукою стабільності української
енергосистими будуть додаткові системи
протиповітряної оборони їх Київ теж
очікує від західних партнерів